Nia Long opens up about the aftermath of
her ex IMEI udoka's cheating scandal
including the devastating way their son
reacted to the news he's a coach in the
NBA how do you guys work everything out
a lot of patience it always feels like
we're dating speaking with The Hollywood
Reporter the actress shares a life
update months after the Boston Celtics
coaches alleged infidelity came to light
the two share 11 year old son kez and
Nia's also Mom to Maasai her son from a
previous relationship Nia says the most
heartbreaking moment came when she saw
kez's face after the Celtics released a
statement suspending udoka as Nia puts
it they decided to make a very private
situation public I think everybody has
to Define their relationship for
themselves especially when you're both
working and you have busy schedules back
in September the NBA suspended email for
the entire season after he was accused
of engaging in a consensual relationship
with a female member of the Celtic staff
breaking the franchise's code of conduct
and the investigation had some twists
and turns and um
took some time to develop all the facts
anio reveals she took Pez out of school
quote it was devastating he still has
moments where it's not easy for him and
I think we have to ask ourselves are we
a part of the problem or are we a part
of the solution after imei's suspension
was announced he offered a public
apology that Reddit part quote I want to
apologize to our players fans the entire
Celtics organization and my family for
letting them down and Nia told ET in a
statement at the time I ask that my
privacy be respected as I process the
recent events above all I am a mother
and will continue to focus on my
children you can be a working mom be
there for your kids and still be the
artist that you are fast forward over
two months later Nia's leaving Boston to
move to LA with her two sons and she's
taking aim at the NBA team claiming no
one from the Celtics has ever called to
see if I'm okay to see if my children
are okay it's very disappointing we make
a determination at a later time about
email's future with us but on the flip
side Nia is also praising those who rush
to her side
Who quote were
felt like I was in this bubble of
protection and that was very comforting
you need to find something you're
passionate about redefine your purpose
with the scandal in the rear view mirror
Nia's got plenty to celebrate I have
something that I need to tell you the
best man cast is getting ready to close
out their final chapter what are you
most excited about getting back with
that group honestly to work with the
cast we fought to make sure that we were
you know supported throughout this
process we love one another we are so
incredibly close we fought to make this
deal happen you know who I want to play
me who Beyonce get your coins together
brother
foreign